[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in today's video i want to
further touch on some exciting news that
hit the papers a few weeks ago
this news of course pertains to the
potential creation
of an hbo harry potter series
now since this news surfaced many fans
myself included
have been questioning the validity of
these claims
despite being featured in various
semi-reliable sources
i think that many of us just aren't
going to be completely convinced
until we get some more concrete evidence
on the production
a harry potter show is the dream of
harry potter fans worldwide but how much
effort is put into it
will be critical to its success
capitalizing on an already popular media
franchise with a prequel or
sequel can be an easy way of gathering
an initial
devout audience but if it isn't done
properly
then it's an easy way to shoot yourself
in the foot affecting the performance of
any future productions
so what's this show about then a harry
potter live-action tv series is in early
development at hbo max
sources tell the hollywood reporter that
executives at the warner media
backstreamer
have engaged in multiple conversations
with potential writers
exploring various ideas that would bring
the beloved property to television
sources say broad ideas have been
discussed as part of the early stage
exploratory meetings expanding the world
of harry potter remains a top
priority for hbo max and warner bros
which along with creator jk rowling
controls rights to the property
harry potter is one of warner's most
valuable pieces of ip
news that talks are underway for a harry
potter tv series
should come as no surprise given the
value of the franchise to warner bros
rowling's seven book series was adapted
as eight feature films
that grossed more than seven billion
worldwide warner also have the fantastic
beasts prequel films
with the third installment coming in
2022 and two more coming afterwards
it makes total sense that warner
brothers would capitalize on their most
valuable ip
and for this reason i think that the
show is likely to happen
however there are certainly some
confusing and conflicting statements
floating around
regarding the production of the show one
statement in particular
released by warner brothers and hbo
almost seems to suggest
that the news is fake there are no harry
potter series in development the studio
or on the streaming platform hbo max and
warner brothers reaffirmed
however i will say this just because it
isn't in development at the studio or
on the platform presently it doesn't
mean that they aren't planning for it
we already knew that it wasn't on the
platform but there still is a
possibility that they've started talking
about it
and given that it's their most valuable
piece of ip
it makes total sense for them to talk
about it in fact the original statement
that was released regarding the show
mentions that they're very early on in
the process
while it's news that executives at hbo
max and warner are engaged in meetings
to find a writer
and pitch for a harry potter tv series
no writers or talent are currently
attached as the conversations are still
in the extremely early stages and no
deals have been made
what do you guys think is the news of
this show legit or not
if it is a real show what do you want to
see let me know in the comment section
below until next time no exceptions
potter
you